don't let me get this straight we are
going to a place that teaches you how to
be a witch yes I think your mama what do
you think for the face this is called
ultimate bucket list we're all going to
choose items from our bucket list to
determine what belongs on the ultimate
bucket list ultimate list we're here in
New York
[Applause]
Joe why don't you lead off ride an
ostrich okay cow be taller
No be a musketeer double Tania
Musketeers what is your name youngster
you mean like sword fight fencing I
think so
so what should the theme be day five
things of god I'm worried because rich
rents are posh go and he'd adventure in
school in my school they stabbed my name
is Brandon machinist I'm one of the
coaches here de Manhattan fencing Center
I want to be a musketeer it's not
dangerous though just a little good
today I'm gonna walk you through the
basics of fencing the outfit yes is it
slimmer I like a giant baby Rachel's
probably gonna be very good at this
that's cool yeah channel Arya Stark
ready to destroy Wow she's very agile
agile and Joe are words that usually go
together
it doesn't look hard that's the thing
lunging and stabbing I think I can do it
hunger you're gonna be ready
agility reflexes you wanna hit why not
to get hit oh it's all about defending
yourself first and then counter taken
I've never done any kind of sword
fighting before but I have a stabber
here do we have to laugh joke over one
and one for all
oh what's going on
[Music]
Rachel seems like humor reacts to a
person and doesn't hold back and just
without their whatever gesture we were
in a movie like Braveheart or whatever
I'm probably on the ground and I saw it
like this Joe would be one of those like
an ogre or a troll with a spiky ball on
a stick
[Music]
it's from my fencing days with daddy our
instructor Keith very chill ha fancy my
chances against the instructor it's
really good good as a date night be a
good blind date go for dinner have a
fight
good choice man you really killed it I
would do another fencing class I had so
much fun but guys there's no time you
don't know what it is yeah karate no
Taekwondo no axe throwing what yeah you
can do it watch your shoes dangerous
thing it's self-defense it's attacking
no it's not attack it's if someone was
to come at you
an axe is a bit like me it's sharp
it's dangerous a little bit heavy
welcome to kick axe throwing my name is
Eden I'm gonna be your expert for today
nice joke and we are going to be
throwing axes I worry that people think
I'm aggressive or something because I'm
choosing to throw axes we've got two
different sized axes here this one which
is our standard one it's about three
pounds it takes a sick man to water put
this on your bucket list cuz I chose
this so it doesn't mean I'm an
aggressive person right no no no no no
there is some sort of innate part in us
that just wants to get out our
aggression by throwing stuff there's so
many things that could go wrong again
axe in the face look oh it's a plastic
one why does he think it's funny to
scare me all the time so the way to
throw an axe weight on the front end
she's straight arms aim at the target
from there you'll shift your body weight
to the back foot as you bring it over
the head behind the back in one fluid
motion you shift forwards let go and
follow through with it it wasn't my idea
to whether throwing an axe is intent
[Music]
like an American version of dart handle
the pressure
that is fun I don't know if it is
selfish
this is all-out attack you know you
always see it in movies and some crazy
character just comes along throws the
axe and it's them and it kills them not
condoning that that's horrendous you
with your friends and yet that's fun
[Applause]
[Music]
that was awesome
like badass feel like for what does he
throw an axe I've got something really
outside the box is it with are you ready
witchcraft
whoa defense the dark arts so it's like
spells so what's your favorite kind of
witch no a sandwich Juke both funny and
a fact at how many sandwiches have you
had today two minutes early okay so let
me get this straight we are going to a
place that teaches you how to be a witch
yes it's called an occult store called
enchantment I think your mama would sue
you think for the face you love Harry
Potter I was in Harry Potter
I've seen Harry Potter I haven't seen
you in there yeah me look in the right
places prefect of Gryffindor House he
was an extra Oh
[Music]
this is cold ladies man's blood of human
blue violet leaf I'm pretty curious
bladderwrack
witch's grass toe of frog too surreal
camp buddy
the other ones a bit obvious this is
very creative it's not self defense
race you know all of this stuff I feel
like I know it though like instinctually
because I'm a witch in my heart
I'm a witch my Emilia rich wasn't Harry
Potter
deep down thinks that he's like a wizard
some of these are in Harry Potter are
they you don't wanna mess with this
stuff this is real deal well no doesn't
really not real deal I'm ready hi I'm
Maya and we're here at enchantments New
York City to tell you guys a little bit
about witchcraft and psychic self
defense I need to eat you guys you maybe
you guys have met in the way we describe
witchcraft that's used for self defense
is called psychic self-defense so the
ideas that you prepare yourself to enter
any situation by encapsulating yourself
well I like to think of it as like a
bubble of protection so do you do like
any rituals or and invisible rituals
laser beams and the sparkle reason you
know you can't always do that you have
to feel them so it's kind of like a
mental vision relation of Defense feel
like that's in the wrong shop they're so
stupid so some folks think of themselves
inside of a condom outside of a condom
yeah like a full-body prophylactic
device is the idea that it's a barrier
between you and the rest of the world
it's really up to you again probably
happens inside of your head what would
yours be Rachel
well it might be heard you mentioned
Glenn's are the good news yeah he went
with the bubble
are you a good witch or a bad witch now
you know what I'm talking about I could
do magic
the sooner we can hex him the better
crossing infants to go with the spell
and there are also a few things that you
can do in the tangible world look at the
culture I feel like there's a shield
around me I see it witching is awesome
[Music]
hey wait oh no no no no that was very
cool spooky spooky the energy and there
was very out of this world and I do feel
more protected but I'm not gonna ride
for fair to have an axe or a sword than
a bubble it's time to decide where
belongs on the ultimate bucket list
animus a word for each one fencing axe
throwing straw witchcraft cookie cool
strong and kooky I'll take that for once
in other news I have Joe's phone which
is amazing
[Music]